And the first of those today will be the
major sin of zena. So first of all, can
you tell me what is the Islamic
perspective on zena and what is the
prescribed punishment in Islam for doing
that sin? Alhamdulillah.
means
illegal sexual intercourse
or when a man and woman who are not
married if they have a sexual
intercourse it's called as zena it means
sexual intercourse outside the marriage
bond
and the Islamic Sharia its basic aim
is to preserve the honor and lineage.
That is the reason zena that is illegal
sexual intercourse. It is a major sin.
And Allah subhanaa tala says in the
Quran in surah Isra chapter number 17
verse number 32 come not close to zena.
Come not close to unlawful sexual
intercourse
for it is a shameful deed and evil
opening other roots to evil. Islam has
tried its best to protect the honor of
the man and the woman. And there are
various guidelines
given in the Sharia and the Quran hadith
which prevents a person from coming
close to zah. Number one is hijab has
been prescribed
and besides hijab for the woman hijab
for the man also. For the woman a
complete body should be covered. The
only part that can be seen are the face
and the hands up to the wrist. Some
scholars say that this should be
covered.
And Allah says about the hijab, Allah
has prescribed the hijab for the man
first in the Quran and then for the
woman. Allah says in the Quran in surah
N chapter number 24 verse number 30. Say
to the believing man that he should
lower his gaze and guard his modesty.
Moment a man looks at a woman, if any
brazen thought, any unashamed thought
comes in his mind, he should lower his
gaze. The next verse speaks about the
hijab for the woman. It says in surah
nur chapter number 24 verse number 31,
say to the believing woman that she
should lower her gaze and guard her
modesty and display not a beauty except
what appears ordinary of and draw her
will over the bosom. And the verse
continues. So basically lowering the
gaze is very important which prevents
zena to a great extent and the
punishment
for this unlawful sexual intercourse
zena. There are two types of punishments
depending upon the type of zena. Zena
can be of two types. Number one is that
unlawful sexual intercourse done by an
unmarried man and woman. It's called as
fornication in English. And if unlawful
sexual intercourse is done by a married
man or woman, it is called as adultery.
The punishment for both it differs.
Allah says in the Quran in surah Nur
chapter number 24 verse number two as
for the woman and man who commit
fornication as for the fornicator be it
a woman or a man fogg each with 100
stripes is give them 100 lashes and let
not your heart be moved towards him
and let a group of believers witness the
punishment.
That means if any man or woman who's not
married, if they have unlawful sexual
intercourse, the punishment is 100
lashes. Flogging them with 100 lashes.
And as far as punishment for adultery is
concerned, unlawful sexual intercourse
done by a married man or woman. It's
mentioned in say Bkari volume number
eight in the book of Udud had number
6814.
A man approaches prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and says that I have
committed adultery.
And the man he bears witness four times
that he has committed adultery. And the
prophet
he ordered that he should be punished.
He should be stoned to death because he
was a married man. So the punishment for
adultery
unlawful sexual intercourse done by
married man in Islam it is stone to
death.
It further mentioned in say bkari volume
number 8 in the book of hud hadith
number 6819 there was a Jew and a Jewish
were caught committing adultery and they
brought to the prophet. The prophet
asked them that in your religion what is
the punishment for adultery? So they
said that our priest had innovated that
the faces should be blackened with
charcoal. The prophet said, "Get your
scripture
and show it to me." The man gets the
scripture and he covers something and
then he reads it. So one of the Sabbath
says, "Please remove your hand." And the
moment the hand was removed, it was
mentioned down there that rajam stoning
to death should be given to a person who
commits adultery. So even in the Jewish
scripture, even in Christian scripture,
the punishment for adultery is thrown
into death. And the prophet commanded
that both of them the Jew and the Jews
both should be stoned to death. It's
mentioned in say Muslim volume number
three in the book of U had number 4191
that the prophet said that anyone who
commits zena
if an unmarried man or woman commit zena
that is do fornication the punishment is
giving 100 lashes and they should be
banished
for one year. And the prophet continues
and says that anyone who does zena,
who's married, anyone who does unlawful
sexual intercourse, does adultery
if a person is married, man or woman,
then the punishment is
giving them 100 stripes, lashing them
100 times and then swinging to death. So
this is a different type of punishment
for zena and it is one of the major sin
in Islam. And in al- kabar
Imam dhabi he gives number 10 to the sin
zena adult in fornication.